hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game I played yesterday in the
Croatian chess League you said that you
would like to see more of my games and I
don't play very often I play maybe a few
classical games a year just uh you know
not to forget how how just displayed as
I I don't have all that much time to
travel for tournaments so I will usually
uh play like like the creation chess
League maybe if if the the team needs me
I'm gonna play like uh my grandfather's
Memorial Tournament that I organize
every year and uh maybe one other
tournament but that's pretty much it so
I don't play often but um I I do enjoy
classical games very much so in the
previous video you said that you would
like to see more so uh here is more my
opponent for this game uh is as then
kovanjia and he's a candidate master and
I'm playing boards too uh yosaro if you
guys know yazaro he also has a chess
Channel he's playing board one uh for
for our chess club uh and it's a very
interesting game uh he I had no idea
what what he would play so so I was I
was ready for uh for everything but
usually in classical chess I don't
really like the over prepare uh I I
figured that when I over prepare I just
um I learned the moves and I get good
positions but I have no idea how to play
them this way I know general or
generally what I want to do I want to
play you know good moves that go into
positions that I understand and then I I
usually play it much better but okay
let's check out the game so he had the
white pieces and he opens with D4 I
played the D5 as I usually do sometimes
I'm gonna I'm gonna play Knight to F6 if
I wanna go for some like maybe the
benoni or or some
um a crazy opening but here it's it's a
team event so I wanted to play a nice
classical opening Knight to F3 Knight to
F6 and he played E3 he went for the coal
system and I played Pawn to E6 later
after we and after we were analyzing the
game uh in in the bar uh yosarov said
that maybe you know you just play
something like C5 don't don't go into
cemento symmetrical opening
uh and you will get positions that you
you prefer playing you're an attacking
player you like uh a crazy position so
you know maybe try not to play Such uh
positional moves but like I said it's a
team event I don't want to mess up the
uh anything for my team so I played a
nice E6 move uh he goes for B3 and I
played Bishop to A7 so just nicely
continuing development Bishop to beat
you I Castle he plays Bishop to D3 and
okay his Bishop Perry is now very nice
uh his Pawn isn't D4 but at some point
the position will open up and his Bishop
should be yeah very good but this also
allows me to as he's really slow playing
this to pretty much go for any plan I
want I can play B6 Pawn to C5 right away
I can go Knight b37 I decided to go for
Knight B to D7 I know I I'm still very
flexible if needed I can even play C6 I
can play C5 of course B6 uh put the
bishop and B7 bring the Rook to C8 and
the usual stuff so here he went Knight B
to D2 and I played Pawn to C5 and okay
this is perfectly fine for both of us he
castles here and I play Pawn to B6 now
my plan is Bishop to B7 Rook to C8 and
then I just wait and see what he does so
he plays Knights the E5 it's the
strongest move and you always will face
this move when um when playing such
positions and uh you know when I was
when I was younger this always bothered
me because I knew that the Knight is so
powerful here and that you you can never
really capture it if a capture is just
gonna have a bad position uh for example
if I go Knight captures he's gonna recap
right now I I have to move my knight and
already he's putting pressure on both D6
and F6 uh his Bishop opens up uh the the
queen can go into the game very easily
uh he can play F4 F5 he like he can do
whatever he wants he can play F4 uh go
for a nice Rook leave Rook to have three
Rook to H3 Rook to G3 so uh all of all
of this becomes possible if I capture on
E5 so I know I can never do that so I
played Bishop to B7 I just continued
development and he plays F4 of course uh
and now Rook the C8 now this is a
well-known position and it has been
reached many many times and um I I
thought about Rook to Seattle Knight E4
usually everyone goes Knight to the E4
first but I have no idea why uh so I
just played Rook to C8 and I I mean I
always have the off of going 90 for it's
the move you you want to play and that
you will have to play he went Queen to
E2 and now I played Knight to E4 I
didn't want to I didn't really want to
play this I wanted to maybe try my uh
options elsewhere I I always like the
idea of maybe playing Rook to C7 uh but
here I just didn't see uh how to make it
work for example if I go Rook to C7 and
he plays A4 now uh you don't really have
the option of going Queen to A8 this is
what I like Queen to A8 and then I can
double up on the C file I have a very
nice pressure here along this diagonal
he can just play A5 so this would be
weird what I could do is stop is A5 by
playing A5 myself but I don't know I I
didn't really like this so let's say
rotate the C1 I'm gonna put the queen on
A8 and now he can even play a move like
a G4 and this G4 was always bothering me
in all of these lines because okay I
know that it's probably not uh
completely winning for white or anything
but uh I put my bishop and queen pretty
much out of the game by putting them on
these diagonal he's never going to open
up the position and I'm just going to
suffer on the king side G5 is coming the
Knight will have to move the queen will
go into the attack maybe some Rook F3
Rook to H3 action I don't want to play
this game where I I have to defend like
this so I thought about Rook to C7 for
quite some time but then I decided
against it and I played Knight to E4 uh
one thing that I also really wanted uh
to try is C4 but I I didn't invest too
much time uh but I had to check because
it looks really nice the point is that
after captures and captures I open up my
Bishop which is great and he can't
really I thought that okay if he
captures with the bishop then I can play
some like B5 then maybe the bishop moves
uh or something then I'm gonna have
pressure on the C2 Pawn but it never
really works uh he can just move the
bush of the back and uh you know it's
it's not nothing spectacular so I wanted
to to make this move work I just
couldn't so I played Knight to the E4 uh
and he uh just continued developing with
uh no he he decided to trade because
um he can mess up my Pawn structure and
he has to decide how to trade it does he
want to capture on D7 or does he want to
capture an E4 now you could do both if
you capture on e4 I'm gonna play D
captures he's gonna put the bishop on C4
B5 let's say Bishop B5 I'm gonna trade
on E5 he's gonna capture and now you get
this position I'm gonna play some like
Queen C7 bring the Rook into the game
and so on it's again a known position
and it has been played before but he
goes for Knight captures on D7 instead
he doesn't go for for the E4 Nike first
captures on D7 this this Lodge is my
queen from the dark squares and uh puts
my queen on a light Square which isn't
ideal but okay I I did offer it and now
uh there are a couple of games that
reach this position C captures and uh D
captures and C5 is a normal also Rotator
D1 is a normal he played Knight captures
an E4 and it is not as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game and okay I
obviously have to recapture D captures
on e4 and he played Bishop to C4
uh it's a nice Square for the bishop and
I always have um problems uh you know I
have to be careful uh Bishop B5 can be
played Bishop D6 can be played he can
trade off the the light Square Bishops
and I have to figure out how to continue
uh playing this I played Bishop to F6
because I I don't want him to be able to
push or to capture on C5 I want his
bishop and B2 to hang as it's undefended
one move that also you could consider is
Bishop to D5 which is very nice if he
ever trades I get to undouble my pawns
and if he plays some like Bishop to B5 I
I can move let's say queen to C7 but now
he can play Bishop to A6 and I thought
that this was just giving his Bishop too
too much and now I have to move the Rook
or I have to trade and then for example
captures captures he plays C4 and uh I
thought that this really gave me nothing
and even though okay I have a double
Pawn here I I felt that uh I I was
better here uh the engine says it's of
course 0.00 but I don't know I I like
the deposition very much so I tried to
make it work I played Bishop to F6
instead and he played Rook F the D1 and
maybe Rook 8 to D1 was a little bit
better here the The Rook on F1 can be
used later on maybe to support a move
like F5 or something but okay he played
Rook after D1 and I played Queen to C7
uh also you could consider some other
moves and I did uh I I I mean I have to
move the queen away from the D file now
all of these uh sorry all of these
captures now become possible and I could
play Queen to E7 but then I was worried
about Bishop to A3 and it just looks
weird and he no longer has to worry
about his Bishop on B2 and uh I I didn't
I didn't like it so after Rook after D1
I played Queen to C7 now I am uh ready
to start capturing on D4 probably
bringing the Rook into the game first so
he played Rook 8 to C1 he also doesn't
want his uh C2 Pawn hanging after all is
said and done so he played rookie to C1
I played rook f38 and now he played C3
because I am ready to start capturing
and D4 he played C3 and here I I really
went into a deep thing guys I was
spending much more time than he did uh
he he played pretty much all of his
moves very quickly uh so I was already
down to maybe 25 minutes here and you
know it's a classical game we both start
with an hour and a half uh but I I
couldn't find a way to improve my
position I know okay I can always
capture on D4 but I don't want to play
that
I I really want to just improve my
position as as much as possible before
making such a committal move the problem
is I I had no idea how to continue uh
playing this uh because I I thought
about A6 I thought about it a lot
because okay if it captures obviously I
can recapture and play Rook day eight
and then the A2 Pawn Falls this would be
good for me but then I thought he's just
gonna play A4 and now my Pawn on A6 is
just stupid I'm gonna have to play A5
and I mean what what is happening now
he's gonna play some like Rudy too he
can double up on the C file he can
double up on the D file it's pretty much
uh he can do whatever he wants so it's a
you know it's a move but I didn't really
find a way for it to work I I can always
play G6 I know that I have to give my
king some breathing room I can you know
uh put the bishop on G7 so it's also an
option one other thing that I did
consider is um the Ponto G5 and I
thought that this would be pretty good
you know because the E3 Pawn is so weak
and I wanted to open up my queen but it
just doesn't work for example captures
captures Queen G4 I just blunder
material even if I try to prepare it
with something like Kinte h8 it's still
not spectacular he can play pretty much
whatever he can just double up your
Apple G5 he's he's just gonna trade
captures captures Rook F1 and okay maybe
maybe you can play this but uh again
it's a team event I don't want to you
know over push it uh you know for my own
benefit just to have fun and then cost
the the team some precious points uh so
I played C captures on D4 I didn't find
um how to make anything else work uh he
of course recaptured Very happily now he
opens up his C file and I have to move
the queen I played Queen to E7 and okay
it's a perfectly fine position again for
both of us he played Pawn to E3 he wants
to get that B4 moving and I played Rook
the C7 now I just want to double up here
again I thought about other moves but I
know that if I if I'm able to double up
then I'm I'm equal or or maybe even
better so uh that's usually how these
positions work out uh and he played
Bishop to A6 it's a very good decision
it's the top engine uh recommendation
and it just offers uh to trade
everything and I thought about this
position quite a lot
um as obviously I did in all positions
as I burned a lot of time throughout
this game and uh I was constantly
thinking what if we trade everything
what if we trade the light score versus
what if we trade the Rooks what if we
trade the queens and what if we are left
with the dark Square Bishops so it's it
would be a uh you know a bishop send
game uh I liked that my Pawn is on a
light Square here I can always play F5
to defend it and he's not going to be
able to touch my touch my pawns on light
squares but he has this Pawn chain and
he has this E3 Pawn the base of the pawn
chain is on a dark square and it's very
weak uh so I thought that you know even
if we go into some sort of a bishop end
game that I can only be better there
okay might not be winning or anything
but uh you know it's definitely playable
uh so having that in mind I just played
Rook B to C8 and I said okay let's let's
trade everything and he did he played
Bishop captures on B7 and I played Rook
captures and C1 now he has to decide how
he wants the recapture does he want to
play a rook captures on C1 first I'm
gonna capture with check and after
Bishop captures I'm gonna play Queen
captures on B7 but then he you know can
play pretty much anything he's gonna
play something like A4 but like I said
it's always better for me because my
dark Square Bishop is better than his
Dark Sword Bishop his dark Square Bishop
is kind of locked in let's say he tries
to bring it into the game I can always
play Bishop to E7 stop this but he will
get uh the first move in with the queen
he will have an active Queen so you know
probably equal position uh so you could
play this uh he decided to go for Bishop
captress on C8 I played Rook back cat
person C8 and now uh this is the the
position that you have and the move I
was expecting uh him uh to play his Rook
to C1 of course you have to counter my
Rook on the C file I'm just gonna trade
let's say captures captures and I get
Queen to C7 and I I get to control the C
file because he had everything in this
game he had a very strong Center he had
a beautiful night on E5 his Bishop pair
was spectacular uh you know the one
thing that I wanted me to have is the C
file like he has everything and I can't
do anything about that but the C file
will be mine and that was basically my
my whole goal this game to somehow uh
you know utilize the C file to my
advantage uh but okay he I would play
this he would play Queen to C uh C4
probably
and I would have to decide whether to
trade or not here probably I would
decide against trading but that also
means giving up the C file for the
moment or because if I trade I know now
the pawn uh the pawns just uh look a bit
too good even though okay these are
still on dark squares and it could be uh
hard to to play but uh you know it looks
very nice like uh one he's one push away
from creating a past Pawn so uh Rook to
C1 is the move that I was expecting
however he played Queen to A6 and I was
very very happy when I saw this because
uh okay he does have some background
pressure here he's putting pressure on
the A7 Pawn he's putting pressure on my
Rook you know I have to be careful but
he also allowed Rook to C2 and I thought
this was giving black a bit too much uh
my my you know first I thought okay he's
giving giving me a bit too much but it's
also possible that I'm just blundering
something am I not seeing something am I
just gonna you know do something
terrible but I couldn't find it I didn't
mess some time here so I just played
Rook to C2 and it is the top engine
recommendation so I mean I I I I I I had
no idea why he allowed this he probably
saw something that a completely
different than from what I saw and here
again I was expecting Rook to see one
you have to play this um because there's
just no other move and then I'm gonna
play Queen to C7 I'm gonna put pressure
on his rook and he's gonna have to go
back Queen to F1 and um my position is
just better I have all sorts of moves
here all sorts of ideas even G5 becomes
possible uh now putting extra pressure
on that E3 Pawn uh so it's it's very
hard for him to play this like it
captures captures I open up my king a
little bit but it's uh it looks very
ugly for him so this is what I thought
that he would play in that he would have
to suffer for the rest of the game
however he played Bishop to C1 and now
the position is completely winning for
me and I was very very happy when I saw
Bishop to C1 I just have to had to you
know uh calculate to see if I'm not
blundering anything because uh it was
such a hard game to play I had to
calculate a lot and pretty much every
plan I checked the checked was uh not
going anywhere so you know I I really
thought I might be blundering something
because
um like in the previous game that I've
I've shown you uh I missed that Rook D5
idea which is like an instant kill for
for white and I was very sad when I
missed that and I thought okay am I
missing something here now but no the
position is completely winning so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this move uh or or rather an idea while
I give you a couple of seconds
foreign
who are able to do it congratulations on
realizing that you have to take control
of the C file and that takes the game
for black and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Queen to C7
this is what I played and uh there's no
coming back from this uh there's an even
uh there's sort of an even stronger
engine move a queen to D7 but this just
looks weird and the engine says okay
white has nothing here the problem is
you really don't have a move for for
white here let's say you try something
like Bishop to D2 there's even Bishop
capture some D4 you know okay you just
grabbed a pawn and the white is
completely lost of course if you capture
captures captures with check King to H1
E3 and white resign so Queen to D7 very
scary move but uh a queen to C7 is the
first move I checked and then I I as I
kept checking I just didn't find a way
for him to actually refute to this idea
um so you know that's why I played it
and I thought that he has to go Queen to
F1 and it is the top engine move but it
doesn't really help white all that uh
the problem is I have Queen to C3 I'm
putting pressure on ether I'm putting
pressure on B3 I'm going to put the
bishop on E7 and there's just not a lot
of ways uh he can play this there's no
move that he can make uh to make his
position better or anything but he
didn't go for this queen to F1 idea
instead after Queen to C7 he just played
Bishop to D2 and I knew um because I
thought about Bishop 32 before I played
Queen to C7 and I found okay it just
loses the game uh but he he missed it so
I was again very very happy that that he
played it uh so feel free to pause the
video for the last time and win the game
for me uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
uh you know nice tactic and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook captures and D2 this is what I
played and it was in this uh position
unmoved 25 that my opponent resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh the problem is uh even though
yes he does have some background
pressure and it seems like I can't
really do all that much with the queen
uh If he if he takes it I just have
Queen to C1 with check now the king will
have to go up the board I'm gonna gobble
up The Rook with check now it doesn't
matter what he plays King F1 I'm just
gonna play G6 create some breeding room
for my king I'm gonna be up a full piece
I mean his pawns are too weak I'm just
gonna gobble them up and that's it so it
was uh pretty much uh I mean it was a
very very exhausting game for me and I
really had no moves basically I could
only play moves that he allowed me to
play and it was a very very hard to even
find playable moves here because
um once I saw that like I don't have
that nice uh a rook to C7 plan here
maybe just go going Rook to C7 maybe
Queen to eight and doubling up on the C
file I don't have that I mean I I I
didn't feel all that great by going for
this Knight E4 idea but it's a movie I
mean it has been played before I had no
idea when I was playing the game but it
it is um uh you know a a good idea to to
make a move like this so it was a fine
game by both of us and we both uh you
know played uh solid moves um pretty
much the position is a dead draw I mean
even after all of these trades maybe
black will always have a little
something uh but I mean after after Rook
to C1 is it should be I mean it should
be completely equal uh however he played
this queen to A6 move allowed me this
one you know a glimpse of activity for
my Rook I took it and it was uh enough
to to win the game and it was just after
this uh you know he he he had a
completely equal position for for like
22 moves uh then he played this one
sub-optimal move Queen to A7 and then it
you know just uh it was a bad move after
a bad move after a bad move and I was
able to win the game so uh very nicely
played by both of us uh in the end it
was uh I who got some luck is he he was
the first to blunder but you know if the
game continued uh if it could also be me
who who would be the first to blunder so
you know I was very happy that that was
not the case in this game uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
not not uh you know a grand master game
like I usually show but you guys said it
you would like to see you know if I play
classical games so uh that's why I I
showed it and I analyzed it in much more
detail when I prepared for a video so I
actually also remember something that I
can use when I'm if I will ever you know
be in similar positions uh so it's also
beneficial for me uh so yeah I mean if
you've learned something that's also
great I actually learned quite a lot to
analyzing this game uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to baji and I would like to thank Marcus
Steele Stefan Connell rushing reptiles
YouTube and Eric haltman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up any
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day